welcome back to Las Vegas now all right
July is national carpet cleaning month
and which is a great reminder to get
your floor some TLC and clean carpets
will not only improve the look of your
home it can also improve your health
we're sadies Martinez has more July is
national carpet cleaning month and
that's a great reminder to give some TLC
to your carpet and we have been mckee
one of the owners and operators from
zero res and you are going to tell us
about why it's so important to get our
carpets clean especially because they're
the largest air filter in your home is
this true it is true if you think about
all the square footage that our carpet
and our soft surface is having a home
they're doing a lot more work filtering
out the air that pollen the pollutants
the dust mold spores then those little
rinky dinky paper filters up in our HVAC
system when a carpet filter when it
starts collecting all that dust at a
point where I can't take any more on it
it's done it's really dirty
you're gonna start finding more dust
bunnies in your home and that's where's
your rugs can come in and get your
carpets cleaned out and get that air
filter reset tell everyone how you guys
differ from the other guy well first and
foremost we've got the best technicians
out there our team not only their
background checked and insured and all
that but they're they're part of the
family we work with them every day to
ensure that they provide the best
customer experience possible and on top
of that we've got the best technology
out there we don't clean with any soaps
or harsh chemicals or fact ins
we don't use any of that stuff and what
that does for you as a homeowner is it
leaves your carpets soft it keeps them
cleaner longer and the best part is it
just dries fast and right now a lot of
people might be a little hesitant on
letting people into their home's how do
you put people's minds at ease when it
comes to something like that in Mercedes
I totally get it I've got a family at
home I'm hesitant to bring in a service
worker to my home during this time
well rest assured I would bring it
zerorez technician into my home we make
sure that there don't have a fever when
they come into work we make sure that
there's no symptoms of coughing or
anything like that and we also provide
the proper PPE do you guys clean
businesses too we have cleaned for over
twenty five hundred businesses here in
Las Vegas in the past 16 years and the
number keeps growing and in fact we
recently we just actually cleaned a
whole Bank a smaller Bank was about to
bring all their employees back in and we
came in we cleaned the sanitize and
disinfect the appropriate surfaces for
them in preparation for them to come
back to a safe clean healthy hygienic
office that's why you guys are the best
zerorez ready to make your home or
business a safe space they're incredible
customer service they're standing by to
help you right now
Google clean three rooms of carpet for
only $99 plus you'll get that free tile
cleaning of a hundred square feet so
call zerorez today their number is 702
eight four zero 33 33 or you can go and
check them out at zero res Las Vegas com